I'm told because you just mentioned your
wife in the last segment that you missed
Valentine's Day was that is that an
issue and if you missed Valentine's Day
yeah you know I I was I was in uh
traveling for Valentine's Day uh working
and and so we missed it but I you know
made sure to get the kids a present and
my wife something before I need to get
your kids something unbalanced yeah for
whatever reason it's now turned into
like a a mini Christmas like they get
full presence
there's candy involved like you're gonna
there's gonna be a holiday involving
candy and your kids aren't going to want
cut in no but what I'm saying is that
why would I mean that's up to the other
kids in their school that's my policy
yeah I get my wife some flowers yeah
well my agent takes care of it yeah yeah
uh and then um but I'm not gonna get my
kids anything for Valentine's Day I know
it's it's not like will you be my
Valentine that's creepy yeah you're
already my like I own you yeah
I made you yeah I made you with my balls
that's where you were going with that
right yeah that's not where I was going
at all yeah yep
what are you doing
it's how it works I like the Hawaiians
that's true
finally something we can get behind a
page of New York Times tomorrow Conan
O'Brien says he made children with his
boss
so uh you're not you don't sound too
sentimental about it no I I actually
early on like I didn't growing up I
didn't know that Valentine's Day was a
real thing I just always figured it was
just a ridiculous Hallmark holiday I
just never took it seriously right until
I was I think in my early 20s I had a
girlfriend and and I was dating this
girl and then Valentine's Day came and
it was I I so I was gonna get her
something so I went to like Walgreens or
something and got her a a microwavable
sandwich press in the like as seen on TV
aisle yeah like for five dollars you
know I thought it was hilarious and I
didn't wrap it or anything I just I was
like here and I thought she would think
it's hilarious
and she didn't think it was funny and
that's when you learned some women take
it very seriously yeah and and uh and
and some do not no that's true some
dudes take it very seriously too right
and apparently your kids to take it very
seriously super seriously they want
money and cash anything